so what does it mean for this symbol to
emerge from the feminine symbol let's
say to emerge from chaos well this
picture this is a picture of Venus the
goddess of love right and so I cut this
picture out of a larger picture and it's
Venus manifesting yourself in a
transcendent space in the sky in the
same way that Christ did in the previous
representation and she has raised coming
off her and there's all these men who
are Knights kneeling in front of the
image well what does that mean well it
means that men used the image of female
perfection to motivate themselves and
that's exactly right that's precisely
what they do you see that in the Tom
Sawyer story so Tom Sawyer is about 12
years old and he's still hanging around
with his friends like Huck Finn and this
wood girl moves across the street Becky
and she comes out and he's struck by her
for the first time in his life
something's changed and the first thing
he does is hop up on a picket fence and
show off and balance in front of her
he's saying well look at me look at me
I'm he's like the male bowerbird
building something beautiful so the
female will approve of it and it's it's
motivation you know and that's something
that I think modern women don't really
understand about men they don't
understand that at least to the degree
that males are uncorrupted and not
better because of being rejected they're
doing everything they can to kneel
before the eternal image of the feminine
and try to make themselves worthy that's
the chivalry story right that's what you
should encourage in your partner so and
so out of chaos emerges this first form
it's the feminine form it's partly the
form that represents novelty as such so
and on one hand its promise on the other
hand its threat that you wouldn't
believe and I don't know because I don't
know I don't understand the situation
with women as well as I understand the
situation with men obviously being a man
but I I don't know if women have any
idea how paralyzing they are to
especially young men a large very large
number of my clinical clients but also
young men I talk to in general are
absolutely terrified of women because
they're terrified of being rejected
the terror exists in precise proportion
to their attraction to the woman which
is a horrible paradoxical situation to
be an insulting wife men make such fools
of themselves in front of women that
they're attracted to it's because first
of all they don't see the woman that
they're attracted to because what the
hell do they know about her they don't
see her as an individual they see her as
the manifestation of a judgmental ideal
and then it's only in establishing the
relationship with the actual woman that
they could start differentiating between
the judgmental ideal and the actual
individual woman and that also requires
the sacrifice and the sacrifice is you
never can have an ideal woman so to have
a relationship with any woman you have
to sacrifice the relationship with the
ideal woman and you have to see the
individual woman and separate her from
the ideal and that's the same thing that
happens to the hero in Sleeping Beauty
right he sees the Evil Queen who
actually turns into the dragon of chaos
and it's not until he can he can defeat
her that he can establish a relationship
with the actual princess and that's
exactly the case I had a one of my
clients who ran this men's group which
was quite interesting one of the things
they had the initiates do which was very
intelligent was to go out and ask 50
women in one day for their phone numbers
why politely properly you know it wasn't
it wasn't this it was a game but it
wasn't a stupid game an idea was get
over your fear of rejection and how do
you do that by encountering it
continually and continually and
continually so that you're no longer
paralyzed by this